um can you did you guys cuz I again I'm
not I I you I told you this off the off
the air I was never like a big fan of
your guys' music but I'm very aware of
you guys and your your Universe you know
did you get twisted ever squash your
guys' uh the Civil War of the the the
jugal world no [__] Twisted I got the
day I die really yeah [__] them [__]
them [__] them I ain't never been
betrayed harder in my life it was it was
a [__] physical pain the way those
[__] betrayed me cuz you guys
did put them on like literally gave them
gave them a fan base right I gave them
the name right they didn't have paint on
they were two other rappers you know
what I mean we signed them put the paint
on created them you know what I'm saying
they got insane Talent you know what I'm
saying but we created that you know what
I'm saying like it was it was what was
the Betrayal the fact that they left you
know they they were dropping end bombs
everywhere and um in the Ws like you
know what I mean and we're like what the
[__] are y'all doing you know what I
mean we had to
[__] hone them in you know what I'm
saying cuz they're talented as [__] they
were talented as [__] you know we had to
hone them in and they're just dumb and
and wild style you know but we [__]
showed them how to do showed them how to
market showed them all that [__] you
know what I'm saying and and BR them on
tour the first time we ever built
ourselves up to go on a national tour on
a bus they were in the [__]
opening you know what I'm saying we just
gave them love I at first The Jug the
jugglers were like when they came out
two guy two other guys in clown P the
Jugos were
like [__] you you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying and it
took us years you know what I mean to
for them to accept them yeah man we were
like these are our boys we're putting
them out Psychopathic you know what I
mean and still people couldn't
understand the idea of Jugo being
something different than ICP right they
didn't want to bring you guys had like
and it was a fat kind of skinny guy just
like you know what mean it's like what
the [__] and then a lot of your guys'
artists ended up with face paint blaz
your Dead Homie and uh
that's what I'm saying we we did our
label like a wrestling yeah brother we
created characters we were like all
right Blaze what what does Blaze do you
know Blaze is from back in the day with
when they wore the clock you know what
I'm saying and Raiders [__] and
everything and he got killed and now
he's supposed to be current rapping that
old [__] that was our idea back then you
know what I'm saying and um and then uh
anybody kill up right he was native
right yeah I was like what do you uh
what's your uh her what are what what is
your ethnicity or whatever and he was
like I'm native and I'm like rep that
because yo the natives love y'all I told
I told him rep that yeah you know what
I'm saying and all your [__] you know
and and we just helped these
[__] and signed them and BR
them on tour and paying all these ninjas
to open for us in front of our own Crown
right right right right I'm [__]
paying these [__] all my life
it was like 10 years 15 years I think 16
years I I did that wit Twisted you know
what I'm saying paying them you know so
was the Betrayal the fact that they left
the label you know what the problem was
bro when they got bigger in the Jugo
world and jugal loved them yeah because
they they became really big right ICP
come to town and draw 2500 or something
on on a good night
right have them on a tour we do the same
thing
same tickets exactly but we're paying
them all this money you know it was that
like that forever mhm that but we we
loved them right you know what I'm
saying then there was a group called um
Axe Murder boys right and um they won a
contest we like had a contest and [__]
to see who were going to sign you know
they won a contest Twisted was like [__]
them you know what I mean they won the
contest they were like they feel why
they they won a contest they deserve be
here [__] them they wouldn't even twisty
wouldn't even let them come in the
studio oh wow right so the the uh one
guy in in X murder boy young Wicked he
was like um he had like a hatred for
Twisted after that you know so years
later when Twisted started their own
label and all that you know what I mean
they signed him huh did they sign that
guy okay no the guy at the I remember at
the Gathering at the Young Wicked show
he's like all I got to say is psychopath
for life [__] that other noise everybody
knew exactly what he was talking about
you know the whole crowd and [__] and um
then
um so when when uh we got betrayed that
[__] they that was when that
dude that dude young Wicked he was my he
was my uh Protege prot yeah he was my
producer I'm putting them on yeah I love
that kid so much I was
like it's my goal I'm sorry take a drink
do your
thing I said I never said this for
anybody I said it's my goal to see you
and your family in living in a paid off
house in Detroit all right with
significant money in the bank that's my
goal right that's what we were working
toward for him because he had his two
kids out there and his girl was pregnant
again you know what I'm saying and that
was his dream to move them here you know
what I'm saying and he wanted to live in
Detroit you know what I'm saying that
[__] got my brother daughter
pregnant you know what I'm saying and
betrayed the [__] hell out of
all of us your brother's daughter yeah
how old was she she was uh of age you
know she was of age okay but but still
that's crazy bro he denied it he denied
it he denied it well he got my brother
told me man it
was no what happened was my brother's
daughter told my brother hey I've been
messing around with uh young Wicked and
my brother was like what and so my
brother didn't tell none of us cuz at
the time he's got a pregnant girl too or
he has a lady got family he's got a
whole know I'm saying that he worships
and puts his [__] on in front of us you
know so my brother's own daughter tells
him hey I've been with young Wicked you
know so my brother pulls that
[__] and in the room in the
office you know what I mean just him and
he's
like stay the [__] away from my daughter
you know what I'm saying she ain't your
local peace my brother's a d at
Psychopathic you know what I'm saying
there's four of us me my brother Joey
and Billy my brother is a Don and this
[__] and my brother said I'm not
going to tell anybody what you did you
know what I'm saying not going to tell
anybody stay the [__] away from my
daughter you know what I'm saying right
that's crazy so a month later my
brother's daughter tells him she still
seeing you know what I'm saying so my
brother had to tell us and it was
like you know so listen all that
happened right when twisted and our us
fell out when you guys had your yeah
right and [__] they signed him the
next like the the day Rob let us know
you guys dropped him there was a picture
the next day him with them like this it
was insane they hated each other for
years yeah they didn't even want him in
the until they had something in common
and that was [__] y [__] yeah on us
and it was insane bro these were my my
Gody my prot like you said yeah anyway I
[__] all that you know yeah [__] them
all man [__] all that [__] anybody
killer all of them [__] Blaze
all them [__] can [__] the [__]
off I hate them so it's safe to say
there'll never be another dark I never
think about them I don't I don't I I see
I'm like I said like I'm I'm aware of
you and twisted issues I didn't know you
had issu everybody else but you you
definitely gave a lot of people a lot of
careers and and the one thing is is but
you know what man if Jug's coming
rocking that [__] or something I don't
give a [__] but I was going to say the
one thing is is you guys have you know I
think some people um don't understand
like if you guys Embrace an artist not
even necessarily somebody who signed to
you you're if you let them into your
world those fans are instant instant if
now we put so many people on they're
going to buy tickets they're going to
buy the shirts and they're going to
support you and they're like the most
dedicated fans there are in music so
well man it's crazy but um it's no
different than than it is on a on a
massive uh Glo Global [__] level like
Jay and everybody you know what I'm
saying it's just kind a smaller thing
you know but it's definitely true if we
if we put out an artist and put them on
Tor and we give them the stamp jug
unless that [__] is something
they reject right you know what I'm
saying which which you know um but that
[__] is granted you're going to be um
making money you're going to be able to
tour you know small clubs and [__] like
we were talking about